[Music]
from
curls to cornrows beehives to bowl cuts
pigtails to dreadlocks keeping our hair
healthy
is a necessity we all share
but if we didn't have any shampoo or
conditioners at our disposal
what would happen to our scalps
if you're follicly challenged well kudos
this video may not apply to you but the
bald truth is
washing your hair may be more important
than you think
what did people use to wash their hair
before
shampoo why could avoiding shampoo in
the short term
be healthy and what are the risks
of poor hair hygiene
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you didn't wash your hair for a year
[Music]
while shampooing your hair may be a part
of your everyday routine
the no poo movement has been gaining
some ground
well just so we're clear the poo i'm
referring to
is shampoo so you can release the
tension now
this no poo movement isn't for everyone
and
may only work for certain hair types
people with dry thin hair that don't
produce much oil
might be in luck but if you've got a
thick head of hair
well take note with
some shampoos containing harsh chemical
detergents that
cause dryness many people are trying
some pretty quirky alternatives to keep
their hair
clean and lustrous but
what did people do before shampoo was
invented
in the indian subcontinent a substance
like shampoo
was made by boiling sependus a tropical
tree with
indian gooseberries the sepindus berries
also known as soap berries contain
saponins
a type of organic chemical that creates
a soapy lather
and it's this lather that helps soak up
any oils
leaving hair soft and manageable the
word
shampoo derives from the sanskrit word
sharpur describing the ancient indian
practice of massaging
and soothing the head and hair ancient
greeks and romans
used olive oil to keep their hair soft
and supple
they would also add a dash of vinegar to
help rinse and
lighten their hair color so if you don't
mind your hair smelling like a salad
well
you can consider that an option in the
medieval
era many people couldn't afford to take
frequent baths
in some parts of europe women were
advised to apply
a mixture of barley salt and bear fat to
their hair to help it grow longer
well at least it was 100 organic
during the renaissance women in italy
used lye soap
alongside bacon fat and licorice as a
conditioner
i like bacon and licorice but i think
i'll just stick to eating them
[Music]
and in the 18th century wig wearing
became a sign of class for both
men and women some doctors even advised
women to
crack eggs over their head to keep their
hair healthy
so if you're ever the victim of an egg
well maybe your hair will thank you
later
take that you bullies it wasn't
until the 1930s that the liquid shampoo
we know and love today became
a widespread phenomenon after 20 years
of heavy marketing in newspapers and
magazines
the trend caught on and the cultural
expectation
of washing your hair had begun
so why exactly are people now avoiding
shampoo
and what would happen if we neglected to
wash our hair
all together well if you don't tend to
exercise very often or live in a dry
climate
you might have better success with the
no washing movement
this is due to a decrease in the
production of natural oils
known as sebum which keep our hair moist
but if you have thick oily hair
you might have bigger problems than a
bad hair day
many people claim that after several
weeks of not washing their hair
it becomes thicker and naturally
voluminous
so in the short term depending on how
oily or dry your hair is
it may benefit you cosmetically and
financially
but if you kept this up for months well
your new do might start to smell a
little funky
you stink
hair traps moisture allowing bacteria to
build up
on unwashed scalps this could lead to an
infection from
all the dead skin cells dirt and
bacteria your hair is mopped up
even if you have a faux hawk a man bun
or a skullet
bacteria finds a way after
a month you'd be dealing with an itchy
scalp
and a sour odor at about
six months to a year the bacteria would
accumulate and clog up your hair
follicles
which could lead to unwanted pimples
hair thinning
hair loss and if you have roommates
possibly eviction
well there's no medical reason to
shampoo your hair
certain types of medicated shampoo can
be a blessing for those
suffering from scalp psoriasis
yet other conditions like eczema or
dandruff
could get worse from regular shampoos
containing harsh detergents
now if all this shampoo business is
wigging you out
i don't like this there are several
alternatives out there like
coconut oil or even baking soda and
apple cider vinegar
but please don't take our word for it
not everyone's hair works in the same
way so
be sure to do your research before
trying anything drastic
and while having long hair might be
making a comeback
what about our fingernails how long
could they grow
if you're itching to know well that's a
story for another
what if